LEAVE.
AND AS HE DID SO, HE SAID TO
THEM, QUOTE, WE LOVE YOU, AND
YOU'RE VERY SPECIAL.
YOU WILL ALSO HEAR IN THE
IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF JANUARY
6th, MEMBER OF THE PRESIDENT'S
FAMILY, WHITE HOUSE STAFF, AND
OTHERS TRIED TO STEP IN TO TRY
TO SAVE THE SITUATION, TO QUOTE,
LAND THE PLANE, BEFORE THE
PRESIDENTIAL DECISION ON JANUARY
20th.
YOU WILL HEAR MEMBERS OF THE
TRUMP CABINET DISCUSSING THE
POSSIBILITY OF INVOKING THE 25th
AMENDMENT AND REPLACING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
MEMBERS OF TRUMP'S OWN CABINET
RESIGNED IMMEDIATELY AFTER
JANUARY 6th.
ONE MEMBER OF THE CABINET
SUGGESTS THAT THE REMAINING
CABINET OFFICERS NEEDED TO TAKE
A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN RUNNING
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT MOST EMBLEMATIC OF THOSE
DAYS IS THIS EXCHANGE OF TEXTS
BETWEEN SEAN HANNITY AND
FORMER -- TRUMP'S PRESS
SECRETARY.
SEAN HANNITY WROTE, IN PART,
NOW, NO MORE CRAZY PEOPLE, NO
MORE STOLEN ELECTION TALK.
YES, IMPEACHMENT AND 25th
AMENDMENT ARE REAL.
MANY PEOPLE WILL QUIT.
>> MS. McCANANEIGH WROTE, LOVE
THAT, THAT'S THE PLAYBOOK.
>> TRUMP KNEW AND MAINTAINED WAS
WILLING TO USE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES TO HIS ENDS, KNEW HE
HAD TO BE CUT OFF FROM ALL THOSE
WHO ENCOURAGED HIM.
THEY KNEW PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
WAS TOO DANGEROUS TO BE LEFT
ALONE, AT LEAST UNTIL HE LEFT
OFFICE ON JANUARY 20th, THESE
ARE IMPORTANT FACTS FOR CONGRESS
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND FULLY.
WHEN A PRESIDENT FAILS TO TAKE
THE STEPS NECESSARY TO PRESERVE
OUR UNION, OR WORSE, CAUSES A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS, WE'RE AT
A MOMENT OF MAXIMUM DANGER FOR
OUR REPUBLIC.
SOME IN THE WHITE HOUSE TOOK
RESPONSIBLE STEPS TO TRY TO
PREVENT JANUARY 6th.
OTHERS EGGED THE PRESIDENT ON.
OTHERS, WHO COULD HAVE ACTED,
REFUSED TO DO SO.
IN THIS CASE, THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNCIL WAS SO CONCERNED ABOUT
POTENTIALLY LAWLESS ACTIVITY
THAT HE THREATENED TO RESIGN
MULTIPLE TIMES.
THAT IS EXCEEDINGLY RARE AND
EXCEEDINGLY SERIOUS.
TO REQUIRES IMMEDIATE ATTENTION,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE ENTIRE TEAM
THREATENS TO RESIGN.
HOWEVER, IN THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE, IT WAS NOT EXCEEDINGLY
RARE AND IT WAS NOT TREATED
SERIOUSLY.
THIS IS A CLIP OF JARED KUSHNER
ADDRESSING MULTIPLE THREATS BY
WHITE HOUSE COUNCIL, AND HIS
TEAM OF LAWYERS TO RESIGN IN THE
WEEKS BEFORE JANUARY 6th.
>> JARED, ARE YOU AWARE OF
INSTANCES WHERE PAT THREATENED
TO RESIGN?
>> LIKE I SAID, MY INTEREST AT
THAT TIME WAS TRYING TO GET AS
MANY PARDONS DONE AND I KNOW HE
WAS ALWAYS, HIM AND THE TEAM
WERE ALWAYS SAYING, OH, WE'RE
GOING TO RESIGN, NOT GOING TO BE
HERE IF THIS HAPPENS, THAT
HAPPENS, SO I TOOK IT UP TO JUST
BE WHINING TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
>> WHINING.
THERE'S A REASON WHY PEOPLE
SERVING IN OUR GOVERNMENT TAKE
AN OATH TO THE CONSTITUTION.
AS OUR FOUNDING FATHERS
RECOGNIZE, DEMOCRACY IS FRAGILE.
PEOPLE IN POSITIONS OF PUBLIC
TRUST ARE DUTY-BOUND TO DEFEND
IT, TO STEP FORWARD WHEN ACTION
IS REQUIRED.
IN OUR COUNTRY, WE DON'T SWEAR
AN OATH TO